اجواء احتفالات عارمه تجتاح كورنيش البصره
احتفالات ابطالها مشجعون عراقيون يشاركهم
مشجعون منتخبات دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
[تصفيق]
عبد الله محمد الدوسري جيت من الدمام يوم
الاربعاء والحمد لله الاجواء والله ما
تنصف ما تنصف انا الان في شط العرب
والصراحه الناس كلها قايمه وناسه بجد ما
اقدر اوصفه الاجواء طيبه وجميله والعالم
فرحانه ومحتفله واهلا وسهلا بجميع
الشقائنا العرب وهذه البصره بصمتكم ان شاء
الله خليجي بصراوي واهلا وسهلا بك
[موسيقى]
رقصات وهذه شعبيه عراقيه وخليجيه تملا هذا
المكان وتبهجوا مرتديه الذين قدموا من
كافه مشارب دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
[تصفيق]
اليوم على الكورنيش على الكورنيش بالالاف
وهذا فخر بان نحنا نجحنا بنقل الصوره الى
الخميس
يعني
ما متوقعينها من الصعوبه بمكاننا الحصول
على موطه قدم في كورنيش البصره الذي
يوميا بالمشجعينه من داخلي وخارج المدينه
من كورنيش البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه